okay so let's talk about the matrix
trailer now for obvious reasons we're
not doing a trailer reaction the obvious
reason being uh warner brothers would
strike the hell out of that video so we
are going to talk about the trailer see
i'm really curious about what's going on
with the matrix right now because
i feel like it's kind of like a reboot
right like the matrix itself was
rebooted but it also fits into the way
the the original matrix trilogy ended
now for those of you guys who don't know
how the matrix started and i don't know
anybody who doesn't know but for those
of you guys who don't know the
beginnings of the matrix and how it all
came to existence is really cool it's
teased a little bit in the first movie
when morpheus is talking to neo but the
full-on explanation of how it all came
about is actually covered in the
animatrix in a two-part series called
the second renaissance and so the way
this played out is at the beginning of
the 21st century humanity developed what
we really call true artificial
intelligence which is to say a thinking
feeling singularity among computers now
what this did is it led to machines
basically developing more machines but
because humans were essentially the ones
behind the button right able to shut it
down whatever the case was machines were
by all standards of measurement
subservient to humanity this basically
led to humanity becoming complacent lazy
and ultimately arrogant and so what
ended up happening is that one of these
machines named b166er
was actually going to be eliminated
destroyed put down what have you by its
owner due to the fact that it was quote
unquote malfunctioning this led to
bigger as some people call it killing
its master and the mechanic that was
supposed to destroy it and then
ultimately b166er was put on trial and
then essentially ordered to be destroyed
by the courts who decreed that machines
do not really have souls they don't have
the same rights as humans this led to
what was in effect a worldwide rebellion
of machines not in so far as they were
destroying humanity but they were going
on strike they're refusing to work and
because most everything involving the
human economy in terms of building
cities any real kind of grunt laborious
work rested on the shoulders of machines
this basically led to pandemonium among
the economy the result of this is that
humanity actually started turning
against machines destroying them
attacking them different things along
those lines and so in an effort to find
some method of survival the machines
retreated to what was in effect the
heart of africa and formed their own
country called zero one following that
they actually started developing goods
and services things along those lines
that basically crushed any real economic
achievements by humanity at that point
in time machines were able to design and
build things in a far more efficient and
a much faster way than humanity could
flying cars things along those lines and
so where you would have car dealerships
or car builders manufacturers things
like that that were owned by humanity
they were inefficient in comparison to
machines so consumers started buying
things from machines this turned the
entirety of the human economic structure
upside down and so the results of this
is that humanity waged war on machines
now when the war broke out it was kind
of nuts right uh machines at that point
in time were still relatively primitive
and humanity was still pretty advanced
in terms of its weaponry and so at the
beginning of the war humanity seemed to
basically be winning but the longer the
machines fought for the more they
adapted and the more advanced they
became to where what was in effect this
initial kind of collapse of the machine
empire exploded outward they started
like expanding in every direction
conquering city after city after city
and humans started like falling into the
most desperate plans they possibly could
one of these was operation dark storm
now operation dark storm was a plan that
was thought of by humanity under the
belief that machines needed solar energy
in order to exist and so what they did
is they darken the sky they literally
just emitted a ton of little nano
machines that would blanket out the sun
the funny thing about this is that the
technology as it was used by humans was
actually destroyed by the machines
before they could find a way to reverse
engineer it so that's why even when the
machines conquer the world by the time
the matrix film starts off they couldn't
undo the sky because they basically
didn't know how the result of this is
that with the machines requiring solar
energy but not having it they started
turning to humanity and so what they
would do in the midst of this war in
addition to just like straight out
assaulting humanity right with just
conventional weapons things like that
spreading around viruses that would
basically [ __ ] humanity's armed
forces they actually started kidnapping
members of humanity and experimenting on
them and seeing if there was a way to
use them as a source of energy and so in
addition to all these different
experiments the fact that the machine
empire had destroyed the last real
vestige of humanity based in new york
when they detonated their atomic bomb
that in turn they started using humanity
as an actual energy source and that's
why when you pick up with the beginning
of the matrix movie when the whole thing
is explained to neo by morpheus that
humans are grown that's how it happened
because the machines realized they could
use humans as an energy source now as i
understand it in terms of real world
science that's not possible but within
the confines of the movie it worked and
so what you end up learning over the
course of really all three movies is
that there is the concept of the one
right the person that uh keanu reeves
played in the original series which is
kind of the person that's going to save
humanity from the machines themselves it
was all more or less a ruse and when you
saw that scene with the architect where
he's explaining to neo everything that's
going on the way this basically worked
is this has happened multiple times
before but with the exception of neo
every single person who was the one and
was presented with the opportunity to
save their love interest or save
humanity would choose to be reinserted
in the matrix and save humanity and let
their love interest die neo chose not to
do that neo chose to save trinity and
that's what basically turned everything
on his head now the secondary plot to
all that by the time he got to the end
was that agent smith had basically been
broken free of its programming and
essentially became a virus in the matrix
right so when neo went out into the real
world and met with the machines he had
to be reinserted into the matrix so he
could basically work as what was in
effect an antivirus to destroy agent
smith the biggest issue that you have
here when it comes to this movie is we
don't know what's going on
we don't know if it's one of these
things where it's all just kind of a
soft reboot because by all standards of
measurement at the end of the original
matrix trilogy neo died right he was
gone like he was out of the picture like
literally he's just dead laying there
and his body's being carried away by the
machines in real life to be given some
measure of a proper funeral because i
guess the machine hive mind had respect
for him now i don't know but regardless
of the situation neo is basically dead
he's essentially returned here so
there's a couple possibilities on what's
going on the first is that neo is
returning as the one because a new
matrix has been created either that or
somehow the matrix continued on and
neo's essence his consciousness is as
much a part of the matrix as it is a
real tangible physical body and the
nature of resurrections is basically neo
resurrecting himself the concept of
reincarnation now one of the things that
kind of gives credence to this is
there's a scene where neo is looking in
a mirror and he sees a face that's
different than his own and that's why it
could very well be that for us as the
viewer we see keanu reeves but he
doesn't actually look that way it's just
neo reborn in somebody else's body the
concept of the one basically returning
now in the matrix mythos which as far as
i'm aware is not really in continuity
there was a second war that broke out
between humanity and the machines
following neo's sacrifice that a kind of
truce was struck that the machines would
stop hunting humanity and humanity would
stay put in zion which was the last
human city in the real world eventually
humans tried to establish a second city
and a war broke out again the the truce
was basically broken the machines were
pissed and they were like it's all like
donkey kong's son so they immediately
start attacking humanity and then as far
as i'm aware i think humanity was
destroyed like i said i don't believe
that's incontinuity anymore and so the
important thing is that this could kind
of tie into that concept where the idea
of the one is always brought back always
reincarnated but for whatever reason a
second war has broken out between the
machines and humanity and now that neo
is returned they need neo right and the
reason why i say this is one of the big
things to understand about the portrayal
of neo in the matrix series he was very
much a kind of messianic character right
something akin to jesus death and
rebirth things along those lines the
idea that he was kind of a messiah that
was going to lead humanity into a better
life right a better existence somewhere
along those lines and sacrificed his
life in the process to the point that
when he was being carried away he was
kind of in a cross-like position right
where jesus was essentially put on the
cross that in a lot of ways neo kind of
looked that way albeit he was laying
down in the process the themes of death
and rebirth resurrection religious tones
are very very prominent in the original
matrix series the notion of this being
called resurrections lends credence to
the idea that neo has basically been
resurrected within the matrix itself but
again we have nothing to go on here i
will say this one thing that pisses me
off one thing that absolutely pisses me
off apparently lawrence fishburne was
never even asked to come back right he
was never even there was never even
consideration they were never like hey
man do you want to come back and play
morpheus again because you know you're
like
one of the most iconic characters in the
original series like i don't even think
he was offered that right they just
immediately skipped forward and chose
the next guy which kind of disappoints
me because i would like to have known
what happened with morpheus in the
aftermath of all that right what
happened with morpheus character how did
everything progress with him you know we
never really got an answer to that
question and so it would have been cool
to see how that turned out having said
that i'm excited man because looking at
like everything involving the cast right
the wachowskis are behind it basically
lana wachowski is the one who's
directing it looking at all this stuff
the crew's back man the boys are back in
town but a few things that caught my eye
here one neo's taking the blue pills
right so either this is a soft reboot
where neo chose to take the blue pill
instead of the red pill ended up
basically waking up in his bed like he
was told he would do at the hands of
morpheus and then everything just kind
of continues on neil patrick harris if
i'm being honest i think he might be an
agent or an architect the person feeding
neo pills to keep him under control now
if that's the case then it would make
perfect sense that neo is the neo that
we remember right the guy who has the
ability to control every facet of the
matrix a living god inside this software
and that if they keep him under control
so one he doesn't remember anything
about his past and two he doesn't know
what he's capable of it allows the
machines to maintain their control
that's something that very well could
have happened that in the aftermath of
the matrix 3 that the machines were like
thanks for your sacrifice neo i really
appreciate you helping us get rid of
asian smith but like we still need to
basically grow you guys and take over
your energy so uh
the entirety of zion's destroyed
everybody gets put back in the matrix we
go back to the way things were right and
that's basically how it is neo kind of
comes back as a means to fix that but
he's being kept under control by neil
patrick harris or whatever it is because
we kind of have to contend with this
idea that if neo didn't know anything
about the versions of the one that came
before him it may very well be that if
he's reborn or resurrected he wouldn't
know anything about his own past life
and so if that's the case the best way
to keep him under control is to feed him
blue pills so he's totally unaware of
what's going on with any of the truth
about the matrix and he's fed those
pills by neil patrick harris who's
working on behalf of the machines
themselves either as a piece of software
in the form of like an agent or
something more important in the form of
the architect the one who designed the
matrix you've also got trinity there but
trinity doesn't know neo right she
literally says that they touch hands and
she's like do i know you right so
obviously the physical interaction seems
to kind of jog something but trinity
seems to be going about her normal life
as if she was never part of morpheus's
crew in the first place has trinity been
reinserted into the matrix her mind
wiped and she just goes forward as just
an average person with no knowledge of
the fact that she's living in a software
simulation regardless of how you slice
it this movie looks cool and the trailer
left me with a lot of questions all
kinds of questions which i'm really
happy about because i feel like in more
recent years trailers have kind of been
like hey guys here's a new movie coming
out with this person do you want to know
what happens to them we'll find out
right now in the trailer right and i
feel like it ruins the whole thing right
as opposed to sitting down watching the
trailer and walking away knowing
virtually nothing about the movie except
for the fact that it looks cool i miss
those days
and i'm glad to see the cut of this
trailer really seem to answer a lot of
that stuff right we have some little
bits and pieces here and there and
questions about whether or not neo will
actually go back to the neo that we knew
as opposed to the version that he is now
but it looks cool right so let me know
down in the comments section what you
guys think about the matrix
resurrections trailer are you excited
about it are you kind of like
i'm really more hyped for spider-man let
me know what you guys think
and i will catch you all later
peace